spicy tuna fish cakes I love this recipe
why because it turns this humble
ingredient a can of tuna into something
delicious
just open up
and drain the tuna into a sieve
just slightly flake that
don't press it too hard otherwise you'll
dry out the tuna
these are water's chestnuts
slicing nice and thin
you can buy them anywhere any
Supermarket chestnuts in
fresh ginger
get rid of that rough skin on the
outside
by grating the ginger you get to get all
that really nice
sort of juice
in
take your spring onions and just slice
on an angle I like the texture of the
water chestnuts
with a spring onion
a touch of fresh coriander
lovely
next remove the seeds from a chili to
reduce its heat without losing any
flavor
and finely chop
chilies and
kaffir lime leaves roll them up
nice and tight bring your knife down the
center
once and just chop
that makes the fish cake nice and
fragrant
such as salt
Touch of pepper
fish sauce
just lightly seasoned
tuna
to bind all those wonderful ingredients
two whole eggs
and give that a nice little whisk
and then
add your eggs get your hands in there
and start mixing
get the mixture
roll it from hand to hand with the Palm
Pat them down nicely
to cook add a little ground oil to a hot
pan at the face of a clock when we go
from 12 all the way around
first one in
these fish cakes only take a few minutes
to cook so keeping track of the order
they go in the pan means you know which
one to turn first
[Music]
the pan a nice gentle little Shake make
sure that nothing's sticking to the
bottom
spatula
two fingers on top turn them over
beautiful that crackling noise is
something you always want because the
tune's already cooked so we're just
lightly frying them to get a nice crisp
outside and gently take them out
smell incredible
let them sit there we're going to make a
really nice delicious simple dipping
sauce start off a little Pinch of Sugar
fish sauce two tablespoons that gives it
the saltiness
one tablespoon of rice wine vinegar
some fresh lime juice squeeze all that
lime in there your fresh coriander lots
of coriander and then give that
a little mix
and then you have the most amazing spicy
tuna fish cakes who would have thought
something as delicious as that can come
out of a can a simple supper in minutes
that's so mouth-wateringly easy and
delicious you're guaranteed to cook it
again and again
first up pasta with tomatoes and
cherries and chilies
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
spicy sauce slice anchovies and garlic
[Music]
dried chilies great for keeping in the
cupboard to add a hit of heat on demand
[Music]
then add the anchovy oil to a hot pan
and Fry the chopped ingredients
add half cherry tomatoes
[Music]
chopped black olives and salted Capers
cook to combine the flavors
in a separate pan boil dry spaghetti
another great store cupboard staple
when the pasta is tender but still firm
drain add to the sauce with a splash of
the water it's full of starch which
gives a great silky consistency
then season with pepper and topped with
basil
packed with big bold flavors and ready
in under 20 minutes pasta with tomatoes
anchovy and chillies
my next deliciously different chili
recipe is grilled corn with Chipotle
chili butter
[Music]
first the topping chopped coriander
then add salt and butter
soaked Chipotle chilies in hot water
these are dried jalapenos which have an
amazing Smoky flavor
drain and chop
[Music]
s together and season
[Music]
next fry corn on the cob in olive oil
you want a really wonderfully charred
flavor
when colored add water to steam through
[Music]
to eat smother the cobs in the butter
and crumble over Lancashire cheese
fantastically messy to eat grilled corn
with Chipotle chili butter and utterly
delicious Smoky treat
my final recipe is a chili classic
jerk chicken
[Music]
start by making the intense jerk
marinade
first Scotch bonnet chilies they may be
small but packed real heat and a fruity
punch
then chop garlic
and fresh thyme
[Music]
for spice add ground cloves cinnamon
nutmeg
and allspice
season with salt and pepper and combine
with olive oil
[Music]
next score chicken legs so the hot spicy
flavors get deep inside the meat
rub thoroughly with the jerk mix and
marinade
add olive oil to a hot dish
[Music]
Brown the marinated chicken for 10
minutes
then add Worcestershire sauce
cover and cook in the oven at 220
degrees for 20 minutes
[Music]
hot spicy jerk chicken easy to make and
Finger Licking Good
beef tacos with Wasabi Mayo
the great thing about street food is
anything goes the Only Rule is they've
got to be really fast and really tasty
now these tacos makes a Mexican and
Japanese flavors into a delicious meaty
mouthful
first off get that pan really nice and
hot these are sirloin steaks
sear it in the pan with all that fat on
I'll add flavor
salt and pepper
a couple tablespoons of olive oil in
pan
nice and hot
hold of the steak
and lay it in always lay away
to the panel a little shake and it stops
the steak from sticking we're looking
for color
and if it sticks it's going to burn
while the steaks are cooking I can go
with my super quick marinade now
two tablespoons of
me soup paste that's a fermented soybean
that gives a really nice sort of Rich
sweetness
tablespoon of sugar a couple tablespoons
rice wine that gives it a really nice
fengary kick a couple tablespoons of
olive oil
salt and pepper
I'm looking for a nice sort of thick
Rich marinade
marinade done it's time to turn the
steaks
it's all the pan
into the other space still based all
we're doing every time is just adding
more and more flavor
take your tongs and sort of lift the
steak on its back and really melt all
that fat down
off with the gas
take them out just take your knife
see all that fat there just slice that
off
I don't want any of that
now in
to the marinade
[Music]
useful
tacos are one of Mexico's most popular
Street Foods they've been made from beef
poor chicken or fish and are loaded up
with amazing sauces and spices
now I want something sort of pickly
cabbage these are Chinese cabbages slice
it in half
and look at it really crisp and really
tasty
I'm going to slice that into quarters
and then just shred it and take your
time
think of cabbage here and you think of
sort of braised
overcooked cabbage nothing worse
but attacker you want freshness
a little season of chili flakes
they sort of discreetly give it a little
bit of heat
a little touch of rice wine vinegar if
you haven't got that fresh lemon juice
small drop of toasted sesame seed oil
give that
a really good mix
now I need something to sort of bring it
together we take some Wasabi paste very
hot very spicy a sort of thumbnail size
I'm going to mix that
a couple of tablespoons of mayonnaise
give that a really good mix
these are basic corn tortilla the trick
is
to sort of color them
and then shape them actually place it
on
the guest room
use some tongs
so it's not to burn yourself
you can also toast your tacos in a
frying pan from there
I'm just gonna place it
on the rolling pin literally 30 seconds
as it cools down the great thing about
serving tacos is people can fill them
themselves just the way they want them
cabbage just squeeze out let marinade
nice rustic Little Mountain
mayonnaise
on
wait to see how soft and delicious and
almost sort of melting in the mouth
texture we've got on this amazing
sirloin so I've got that really nice
see her around the outside
just nice and pink in the middle
start off with my crispy shell back of
the spoon with the Wasabi mayonnaise
inside taco
just sprinkle
that delicious
pickled cabbage
and then just
start lining my attacker with three or
four slices
touch more
am I spicy
Maya
that is how I'd make
the perfect attacker
[Music]